nos trois invités c'est donc le
décryptage et nous sommes avec benjamin
marc professeur d'histoire et porte
parole cgt 94 bonsoir benjamin arnau
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire maxime
thiébaut docteur en droit bonsoir
messieurs merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on va essayer
d'être clair si on peut l'être parce que
c'est vrai que c'est toujours un petit
peu compliqué je ne sais pas si de votre
côté c'est d'une clarté
voilà limpide mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
essayer de décrypter ce discours avec
des vacances des zones qui se mélangent
voilà bonne chance pour pour les parents
benjamin a marre vous l'enseignant vous
qui avez eu d'ailleurs le coc vide on se
souvient qu'ils étaient très en pointe
sur les fermetures d'écoles pendant de
nombreux mois
votre réaction déjà concernant ce qui va
modifier la vie de nombreux français et
de nombreux parents cette fermeture des
écoles cette modification du calendrier
scolaire c'est ce qu'on vous attendiez
sur cette question sur cet aspect là
très précisément rappelons que ce que
nous demandions depuis maintenant un
certain temps depuis la rentrée c'était
que si on partait du constat des manuels
macron que nous sommes en guerre contre
le coc vide 19 alors si on est en guerre
on met les moyens et nous on était
d'accord avec l'idée qu'il fallait à
tout prix éviter la fermeture des écoles
mais dans ces cas là il fallait se
donner les moyens
je rappelle que les deux me groupe dans
les lycées on les a gagnés à l'huile de
coude après une semaine de mobilisation
un monsieur lancker cède au bout de cinq
jours de mobilisation d'ailleurs je vais
vous dire un truc dans mon lycée on a eu
des retraits sur salaire pour le droit
de retrait qu'on a exercé
voilà c'est vous dire alors que de mes
groupes sont toujours actée et donc il a
fallu se bagarrer dont on ne cesse de
demander depuis la réquisition de
bâtiments des recrutements
extraordinaire de personnel et de cette
manière là on aurait pu à la fois faire
baisser la circulation du virus est en
même temps assurer un encadrement
pédagogique de qualité en prenant compte
effectivement les règles année terme est
rien
et effet ce sont toujours les mêmes
règles libérales et donc qu'est-ce qui
se passe eh bien le montra du
gouvernement c'était on ne ferme pas les
écoles voilà comme comment dire une
moule accroché à son rocher il répétait
sa 116 et bien au bout d'un moment
fatalement ce sur quoi ils avaient parié
fondé toute leur stratégie s'est fondée
on ferme les écoles mais parce qu'encore
une fois et c'est d'ailleurs le sens que
je donne moi cette intervention
finalement c'est le même disque rayé que
l'année dernière quand monsieur macron
avait ce ton mélodramatique en 2020 bon
très bien mais là c'est le même pathos
alors que la pandémie est là depuis un
an
donc c'est le constat d'un échec d'abord
dans l'éducation je viens de vous dire
pourquoi mais également sur les autres
secteurs
arnaud benedetti on va essayer voilà de
prendre un peu de hauteur et d'y voir
plus clair sur cette tonalité de
discours déjà vous le communicant macron
qui essaye mais nous sommes les cons qui
essayent davantage de responsabilités
rézé les français avec un confinement
qui s'étend à tout le territoire mais
pas de confinement strict votre réaction
globale ce soit de la nation sur un même
thème en l'occurrence la politique court
après le virus et la communication coup
après la politique en l'occurrence c'est
ce qui caractérise finalement je crois
cette intervention de ce soir on a eu
d'abord toute une séquence avec des
pré-annonces qui finalement ont été
certifiés et confirmée par le président
de la république avec cette allocution
devant les françaises et les français
donc il n'y a pas véritablement l effet
de nouveauté parce qu'à partir du moment
où l'elysée avait fait le show en termes
de communication de laisser fuiter ce
cas les dires le président de la
république on s'attendait pour
l'essentiel à ce qu'ils allaient à le
penser
donc il n'y a strictement aucun l'effet
de surprise dans la communication de
l'exécutif
ensuite manifestement moi moi il ya une
formule qui m'a vraiment frappé en fin
d'intervention il a parlé de la teneur
il a dit on va prendre obtenez
l'épidémie entre une stratégie qui
consiste à accélérer la vaccination et à
freiner l'épidémie par un niveau de
relèvement des contraintes mais en fait
son inconscient à parler d'eux
d'une certaine façon la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui c'est sa stratégie qu'il
est en tenaille et c'est comme ça que
une grande partie de l'opinion perçoit
ce qui est en train de se passer depuis
quelques semaines c'est à dire qu'il a
fait un choix le 29 janvier qui était un
choix contre l'avis de son conseil
scientifique c'est à dire de re confiné
alors c'est un choix qui peut être
pouvait s'entendre moi je n'ai aucune
compétence d'épidémiologistes en la
matière mais manifestement les faits ont
démontré que cette fois ci les modèles
épidémiologiques avait été présenté au
président de la république au mois de
janvier se sont confirmées pour le mois
de mars
donc on a toujours un sentiment de
malaise avec cette communication parce
que c'est une communication qui donne
l'impression d'abord de vouloir
absolument protéger et justifier les
options qui ont été celles de l'exécutif
ensuite on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
clairement on est dans une situation où
le président continue à essayer de
trouver une marche d'une heure entre les
nécessités économiques et les nécessités
salutaire je ne suis pas sûr que la
multiplication des annonces qu'il a pu
faire aujourd'hui dans cet exercice ce
soit en tout cas immédiatement audible
et nécessitera vrai sens moment un
décryptage dans les heures qui viennent
maxime thibeault vous le docteur en
droit comment vous percevez ce soir
c'est énonce des manuels mettront parce
que c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois ça
semble être un roulement de tambour on
attend voilà je vais être un petit peu
taquiné que le roi de france nous disent
qu'on a le droit de faire ou ne pas
faire
votre réaction ce soir on avait eu les
ballons d'essai c'est à dire qu'il avait
déjà commencé de confiner sans vouloir
utiliser le terme parce que pour lui le
confinement c'est le symbole de son
échec à tout prix il ne voulait pas
confiné il avait déjà commencé de
remettre des restrictions dans certaines
régions et ce soir il les a généralisé
on le savait on savait d'avancé pour
fait ils tendaient vers une
acceptabilité des mesures parce que
l'objectif des manuels macro et c'est
comme ça qu'il gouverne depuis le début
il n'est pas là pour représenter la vo
lu la volonté populaire il n'est pas là
pour avoir l'accord des français
lorsqu'il prend une décision il est là
pour entraîner
cette tension de ces derniers des
mesures qu'il va décider dont il avait
commencé de le faire avec le confinement
à paris du moins les mesures qu'on a
connu à paris l'affairé avec lyon il l'a
fait avec pas mal de départements il en
fait l'application à toutes les
métropoles françaises et il est venu
finalement à l'étendre sur l'ensemble du
territoire national donc on ne voit
aucune différence
moi ce qui me dérange fondamentalement
c'est que on a la preuve est en tout cas
eux n'ont pas la preuve que les mesures
de restriction sont efficaces pour
lutter efficacement contre le coc vide
aux cantons commencent à faire la
comparaison internationale
on voit que des états comme la suède des
états comme l'espagne et des états
fédérés des états unis d'amérique n'ont
pas eu des mesures aussi forte en terme
de restrictions sanitaires et pour
autant n'ont pas eu une évolution de
l'épidémie
au point d'avoir les quatre cent mille
morts que nous annonçait manuel
backrooms à 2 décembre
et ça ça me dérange parce qu'en réalité
on a encore vu ce soir une
concrétisation d'un principe qui à mon
sens et illibérale c'est le principe de
précaution l'objectif d' emmanuel macron
c'est de prévenir tout problème d'un
point de vue de sa responsabilité
politique et de la point de vue de la
responsabilité pénale de ses ministres
en ayant des mesures qui sont parfois
plus contraignant que nécessaire et vous
avez une étude l'étude vigile qui a été
rendu il semblait hier qui a démontré
que dans les écoles la maladie n'a pas
évolué le taux en fait d'incidence
évolué parce qu'on fait beaucoup plus de
tests mais le nom de tests positifs
reste le même c'est à dire à peu près 3
4% et on a eu toute une communication
d'emmanuel macro pour nous faire peur
pour nous faire peur nous faire peur que
nos enfants tombent malades et que
derrière et donne la maladie à nos
parents à nos grands parents pour
conduire finalement la fermeture de
l'école c'est c'est je trouve terrible
parce qu'on met toujours sur le même
triptyque qui est assez simple l'émotion
par la peur l'infantilisation et là il
ya juste un point positif c'est qu'il a
supprimée l'attestation dans le
périmètre de 10 km heureusement que
c'était le symbole de cette
infantilisation et le troisième c'est la
culpabilisation et ça c'est assez c'est
assez trainer je suis pas un expert en
communication et d'eau
et il me reprendra certainement mais
vous avez toujours des messages positifs
qui sont ponctuées de la part d'
emmanuel macron par des sortes de
compliments ou de deux petites remarques
en disant vous avez fait des efforts ou
bien vous n'en avez pas assez fait ou
bien vous penserez en faire davantage
pour faire culpabiliser les français
comme si en réalité l'épidémie était de
leur faute
alors qu'en réalité elle est de la faute
de ce gouvernement qui n'a pas suggéré
la politique vaccinale et il n'a pas eu
une politique concrète depuis un an
en tout cas maxime c'est beau ça ta
culpabilité le gouvernement ne semble
pas se l'appliquer pas de mea culpa de
la part du chef de l'état que l'on
écoute là où beaucoup de nos voisins ont
décidé de confiner il y a maintenant
quatre mois
nos voisins allemands par exemple là où
nos amis italiens en sont à leur
quatrième confinement nous avons aussi
par ses choix collectifs que nous avons
fait gagner des jours précieux de
liberté des semaines d'apprentissage
pour nos enfants
nous avons permis à des centaines de
milliers de travailleurs de garder la
tête hors de l'eau sans jamais perdre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
nous avons donc je le crois bien fait
croire en la responsabilité des français
ça n'est jamais un pari ça c'est vrai
que c'est récurrent à ceux qui suivent
les traditionnelle conférence de presse
du jeudi a rarement un mea culpa nous
avons bien fait nous dit emmanuel macron
ce soir benjamin a marre votre réaction
quant à cette non remise en cause de la
part du gouvernement macro et du chef de
l'état lui-même à côté c'est pas dit mot
quand j'ai préparé l'émission fa le
j'écoutais assidûment ce qu'avait dit le
président j'avais une feuille à côté
cette phrase les creed
elle est hallucinante elle est
hallucinant parce qu'en fait on touche
là je pense à la fois quelque chose qui
relève de la psychologie individuelle
des manuels mâcon mais qui a pour le
coup ruisselé dans toute sa majorité
c'est à dire que ces gens au niveau de
la morgue et de l'arrogance jeu
qu'ils ont leur douzième dan à ce niveau
là c'est de la virtuosité
on a une situation sanitaire
hallucinante on vient d'évoquer quel
point emmanuel macron avait été
finalement en contradiction avec le
conseil scientifique et à tort mais il
nous explique qu'il a tous mieux fait et
mieux fait partout ailleurs c'est
sidérant les bras m'en tombent
mais moi j'aimerais réagir aussi sur
autre chose au départ il a le toupet aux
éditions dit la route pas de parler de
solidarité
doit-on rappeler ou alors est ce que
nous avons tous des problèmes de mémoire
tampon qu emmanuel macron à imposer au
mois de janvier une réforme de l'aide au
logement qui va se solder par 700
millions d'euros des dents - pour les
allocataires et qu'il met en place au
forceps une réforme de l'unedic
unanimement condamnée par les
partenaires sociaux
voilà et après ce monsieur a le culot de
venir nous parler de la solidarité
alors qu'on a 1 millions de pauvres
supplémentaires voilà la messe est dite
voilà pourquoi je vous disais tout à
l'heure le même jour box rayé et avec
effectivement toujours la même petite
musique du satisfecit et de l'auto
satisfaction
voilà césar jupiter se desserre l'a
lui-même des lauriers mais un moment ou
un autre
fatalement il y aura un retour de
boomerang parce que pour les français je
sais pas comment l'opinion va ressentir
cela en tout cas moi je trouve ça
insupportable
on va poser la question communiquant en
aube énergétiquement l'opinion justement
va recevoir tout ça c'est vrai qu on a
du mal on digère tous un petit peu les
les mesures ceux qui ont des enfants
sont en train de faire leurs calculs mon
dieu qu'est ce qu'on va en faire parce
que dans deux jours il va falloir qu'il
reste la maison si j'ai bien compris en
ses enfants c'est pas aisée pour tout le
monde
votre avis justement pour cette
acceptabilité de l'opinion publique
comment vous la sentez brésil jusqu'à
maintenant mais il ya quand même une
l'autre continue qui a accompagné la
gestion de cette crise sanitaire et des
études d'opinion qui ont été effectués
depuis le début de cette gestion ont
démontré c'est que il ya une méfiance et
l'absence de confiance dans la façon
dont l'exécutif gère cette crise depuis
le début depuis le mois de mars de
l'année dernière donc cette tonalité à
mon sens
après le discours du président de la
république ce soir ne devrait pas
fondamentalement évolué et moi je suis
quand même très surpris par la
multiplicité des annonces ou des demies
annonces qui sont faites on a
l'impression d'un président de la
république est au milieu du gué qui ne
veut jamais faire le pas supplémentaire
dans une direction dont une autre comme
s'il gérait au doigt mouillé cette
épidémie et c'est ce qui ressort quand
même des discussions d'ailleurs qu'on
peut avoir avec les françaises et
défense et lorsqu'on lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
les interroge c'est à dire qu' il ne
voit pas véritablement la stratégie
globale qui guident l'exécutif dans la
gestion de cette épidémie par contre ce
qu'il sorte c'est que la question des
moyens à la question de l'organisation
la question de la logistique qui est la
question matricielle des des
dysfonctionnements dans cette crise
depuis le début persiste c'est à dire
qu'en fait le décor général n'a pas
fondamentalement changé par rapport à
celui de mars 2020 et ce sentiment de
surplace alors évidemment le président
de la république a essayé de combattre
en fin d'allocution on annonce ont de
manière à mon sens très audacieuse
calendrier de réouverture pour le début
du mois de mai afin de donner un peu de
perspective est un peu d'espoir aux
françaises et aux français et est ce que
ce sera suffisant pour les convaincre on
peut avoir aujourd'hui des doutes
contenu quand même delà de la façon dont
le le le pays réagit par rapport à la
gestion de cette de cette épidémie
effectivement je vais pas demander
puisque a pas de médecins sur ce plateau
l'efficacité de ces mesures mais on peut
peut-être je ne sais pas en douter
concrètement ça veut dire quoi que
pendant trois semaines d'école cc salle
le gros des annonces ce soir c'est le
confinement nationale mais finalement
enfin on a on a du mal finalement avoir
les effets de ces nouvelles annonces
maxime thibeault 7000 id réa qui passe à
dix mille lits est ce que c'est bien
suffisant aujourd'hui alors qu'il me
semble qu'à nice
on a des lits de réanimation qui sont en
train de fermer et que depuis trente ans
on a une politique en terre sur le
service public hospitalier a été
désastreuse et qui a été celle de passer
d'un hôpital de stock
c'est à dire qu'ils prévoient des nids
vers un hôpital de flux qui n'a plus la
capacité de répondre aux crises mais qui
répond au tout venant des malades
je note qu'une chose et ça il faut il
faut bien de soulever à chaque fois que
vous avez un contentieux devant le
conseil d'état
et dernièrement vous avez le cercle
droits et libertés qui a saisi le
conseil d'état en référé liberté contre
le couvre-feu est bien le gouvernement
n'a pas pu apporter la preuve que ces
mesures étaient efficaces pour lutter
contre le coc vide aucune preuve et même
le conseil d'état les cris le conseil
d'état dit il le semble que ces mesures
aient permis finalement de lutter contre
le comité il n'y a aucune preuve
et ça c'est vraiment problématique c'est
à dire que je reviens le principe de
précaution ce principe de précaution y
conduit derrière à des privations de
liberté qui sont terribles et a des
conséquences de ces mesures de
restrictions qu'ils le sont aussi
on a vu le nombre de suicides augmentent
et on a vu le nombre de dépressions chez
les enfants chez les étudiants on a vu
le nombre de fans de maladies
psychologiques a explosé on a vu les
problèmes dans l'éducation de nos
enfants notamment les plus petits par le
fait qu' ils subissaient les mesures de
restriction et ce qui me gêne beaucoup
c'est que le gouvernement ne fasse pas
preuve de précaution vis-à-vis des
autres aspects de la vie et reste dans
un raisonnement par bon pied purement 7
taurian c'est à dire que emmanuel macron
à l' influence de médecins qui sont en
plus des pompiers pyromanes
les médecins de plateaux télé qu'on va
toute la journée sont parmi les
responsables de la politique
hospitalière qu'on a connu depuis trente
ans donc c'est quand même
particulièrement désastreux mais il
donne la parole
il laisse parler ses personnes qui ont
un raisonnement purement sectorielle qui
le regardent que des courbes et qui ont
finalement oublié ce qui est le serment
d'hippocrate et qui est celui de
car la vie dans sa globalité et il les
écoute en oubliant que la vie entière
est en train finalement d'être
progressivement abandonné et
progressivement les français tombent
dans un état psychologique qui est de
pire en pire et moi c'est le vrai
problème et je regrette emmanuel macron
maintenant même pas là dessus en tout
cas est la seule solution pour me et
d'ailleurs pour tout le monde ça semble
être la vaccination benjamin marge de
vous interpeller justement on parlait de
cette piste la vaccination avancée pour
les enseignants ça ne semble pas être le
cas ils devront patienter en tout cas ça
sera en fonction de l'âge
c'est une déception dans les écoles
j'imagine pour les enseignants que vous
êtes
c'est un sujet de plaisanteries acides
dans la salle des profs en tout cas dans
mon établissement puisque s'ils
voulaient encore une fois on a
régulièrement ces exercices de prise de
parole gouvernemental ou présidentielle
où on nous annonce des trucs en
s'imaginant que j'en oublie ban on se
souvient qu'en janvier
monsieur blanc caire nous proposer une
une vaccination en autour de la mi mars
puis ensuite effectivement ça s'est
reportée sur la mi avril
et puis ça va être les calendes grecques
mais je vais vous donner un autre
exemple si vous me le permettez plus
plus personnel emmanuel macron à dire
quand vous avez des problèmes de diabète
et d'hypertension artérielle et bien
vous allez chez votre médecin il pourra
effectivement vous vacciner art
astrazeneca brut ils savent quoi moi
j'ai glee père tension c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui m'a valu la forme grave du creux
vide 19 qui d'ailleurs a fait exploser
ma tension artérielle il faut le savoir
eh bien quand j'ai vu mon médecin il ya
de ça arrive dix jours je lui ai dit
mais alors comment ça se passe il me dit
va écouter
je vais vous faire une attestation avec
votre hypertension artérielle
on va voir essayer de jouer le coup dans
les centres de vaccination peut-être à
partir de la mi-mai essayer de voir si
vous allez si vous aviez arrivez à vous
faire vacciner surtout par l'astre à
zenica
parce que quand on est jeune comme vous
ça peut créer des thromboses donc voilà
entre la messe présidentielle et la
réalité du terrain que ce soit dans la
salle des profs dont le cabinet du
médecin voyez il ya une galaxie et ça
aussi ça nourrit bien évidemment le
mécontentement la colère et une certaine
forme de lassitude extrême
merci en tout cas à tous les trois je
rappelle en ce calendrier de vaccination
31 mars et plus de 70
en 16 avril les plus de 60 ans et le 15
mai donc les plus de lait - pardon les
plus de 50 ans excusez moi on seront
hyper merci à tous les trois messieurs
match à marnoz benedetti et maxime
thiébaut merci d'avoir été avec nous
pour commenter donc ces annonces des
manuels macron